all right we are going to do a deep dive
into the
bowels of the republican party and we
are going to see that through the lens
of a completely deranged and demented
speech given by the former president
donald trump in phoenix arizona over the
weekend the context of this speech was
that it was one of these turning point
usa that's that college republican group
it was a turning point usa event in
phoenix in support of the election
audits or arditz as some call them which
some republicans still believe are
imminently going to lead to the
reinstatement of donald trump now none
of that is going to happen
it's hard to even call the audit an
audit but
we learn so much from this speech about
the state of the average republican
voter so let's get right into it first
of all
just the introduction for donald trump
is beyond parody satire is dead trump
coming out to dubstep mixed in with that
lame country song that we're supposed to
pretend that a rich guy from queens
actually likes take a look at this
do you miss me yet
ladies and gentlemen
please welcome the 45th president of the
united states of america
donald j
trump
[Applause]
okay so you get it completely beyond
parody unable to be satired uh putting
saturday night live completely out of
business
but the content the content was a mix of
lies
yes
delusions of course and also just
completely unintelligible statements in
this clip trump refers to the authors of
the audit i assume he means the auditors
he also instead of talking about
affidavits
he seems to say affidavit
it's all weird
we can't let this happen yet this is
only the beginning of the irregularities
the arizona audit is uncovering the
authors
and the auditors have collected
a sworn affidavit stating
so the auditors have uncovered the
authors
and the authors
found affidatus
so you know that seems to be listen if
you want a predictor as to whether these
audits will have an impact the fact that
trump says that they are authors finding
affidatus it's all not good it's all not
good and then maybe in the most bizarre
moment of the entire speech
donald trump repeating the word routers
more than 10 times in 36 seconds i
challenge you to prove that trump even
knows what a router is the county has
for whatever reason also refused to
produce the network routers we want the
routers sunny wendy we got to get those
routers please
the routers
come on kelly we can get those routers
those routers
you know what we're so beyond the
routers there's so many fraudulent votes
without are we because you don't sound
like you're beyond them but if you got
those routers what that will show and
they don't want to give up the routers
they don't want to give them they are
fighting like hell why are these
commissioners fighting not to give the
routers how simple could it be that will
tell the truth so that's very strange
something really weird going on there
almost like trump falling into some kind
of
linguistic black hole where he just
can't keep we can't stop repeating the
same word and then we go from confusion
to just lies trump says that the real
big lie
is that joe biden won in other words
the lie being told is biden won
the truth as trump sees it is he
actually was the winner in november now
nine months ago
the big lie they call it you know what's
the big lie
the opposite is the big lie
election was the big lie
and i've got to tell you i i've got to
say this i've never said it before but
i've always thought it
uh oh if i lost the election i'm okay
with that i'm okay with it seriously if
we lost the election we'll lose an
election
i'll go home
i'll start building buildings i'll do
something i'll keep myself busy now this
is funny because he did lose and he
promised before if i lose you won't see
me again and yet here he is in like
speech number five or six since losing
the election but he just continued his
argument is i didn't actually lose but
you know what
if we lost the election we know when we
lose you don't yeah so there's there's
that um and then uh trump just
continuing with this stuff let's look at
one more of these if i lost this
election i could handle it pretty easily
when they steal it from you and rig it
that's not easy and we have to fight we
have no choice
so there it is that's what i alluded to
before which is
trump just doesn't believe that he lost
he says if i lost i would accept losing
and i would be fine i would be a big boy
i would be an adult well but sir this
time sir sure you're not actually acting
like an adult
but you said you would well no it's
because i didn't actually lose oh okay
okay i mean just completely disconnected
and the crowd cheering is a real sign to
us the fact that these crowds continue
to believe this tells us a lot about the
state of the republican electorate at
this point in time then trump again sort
of alludes to the idea that
once these audits are done
he'll be back in office and of course
there's no mechanism for such
reinstatement and of course the audits
aren't real audits and of course he
didn't actually win and you know i don't
think i need to tell you they almost got
away with it
they may have gotten away with it we're
gonna find out because something's gonna
have to be done something i don't think
so something i don't think so you know
if somebody robs
tiffany a beautiful jeweler 57th and
fifth good location excellent location
and they steal the diamonds
and then they get caught they have to
turn the diamonds back the diamonds it's
very simple
amazing the way it works
so apparently returning stolen jewelry
to tiffany's at 57th and 5th is
equivalent to
the reinstatement of a president nine
months post an election
uh it's all very very strange and you
and i might say david who could possibly
believe that at this point the people in
the crowd at least some of them seem to
believe it check out what donald trump
then claimed about the first six months
of joe biden's presidency but you know
what if instead of doing the horrible
they're saying it was the worst six
months
in the history of the presidency i don't
know that that's true but i would say it
is if you but you know it's not true
trump's instinct there i don't know if
it's true
what what's what's amazing to me about
that is all the people saying we've gone
down a communist spiral and it's all
dystopian and it's all terrible
socialist marxists etc
imagine being so disconnected from
reality that you believe biden has even
done that much one way or the other i
mean quite frankly
many people myself included wish that
joe biden had done more now there might
be people who would disagree with the
stuff biden did if he did it and people
who would agree but he's just not done
that much he did some executive orders
right up front to reverse some of the
most atrocious things that donald trump
did he got coveted stimulus passed which
was a great thing but it's relatively
low hanging fruit globally europe looks
at the controversy that took place here
over biden's covet stimulus package
which republicans were against despite
signing off right away on the trump
stimulus packages which were very very
similar
he
he hasn't even done that much one way or
the other and the idea that in six
months so much has happened
aside from whether you like it that this
would be the most significant anything
six months of a presidency it's just
imaginary and then trump starts leaning
more heavily on the communist stuff
like it or not we are becoming a
communist country that's what's
happening i continue to recommend that
when people say that say what does
communist mean what can you define
communism what exactly is a communist
society an economy a government it's a
really fun experiment because it goes
nowhere and then donald trump
recommending the vaccine but also
recommending freedom we are at the
beginning of a communist system radicals
are seizing power and destroying
everything we hold dear as americans
okay so that's more on the communism
stuff then trump recommends the vaccine
but also recommends freedom it's like
what does that mean i mean how about the
vaccine i came up with the vaccine they
said it would take three to five years
gonna save the world i recommend you
take it but i also believe in your
freedoms a hundred percent but just so
you understand
but it was a great achievement and
notice the crowd is not cheering for i
recommend the vaccine the crowd is
cheering for
i recommend freedom and that's you know
i recommend you take it but i also
recommend freedom yeah
and the delusional nature of i came up
with the vaccine i mean aside from the
fact that
you know it's scientists and and people
in medicine who come up with the vaccine
the idea that trump did anything other
than just pre-purchase some vaccines is
laughable at this point it's crazy that
he's even still repeating that and then
trump finally gets to the topic of
running in 2024 and he says you know
when when i talk about people tell me
running in 2024 i just won an election
why do i need to run again you're way
ahead of everybody
running 24 sir you're gonna win
and i say wait a minute i just won six
months ago
congratulations sir you just won the
election yeah so trump uh insisting run
again i just won this thing as many of
you know the election the olympics are
going on and then donald trump started
sort of goading the audience into booing
the u.s women's soccer team which
doesn't sound
particularly patriotic to me
demented the u.s women's soccer team is
a very good example of what's going on
earlier this week
they unexpectedly lost
to sweden
three to nothing
and people are cheering the loss of the
u.s women so i thought this was all
about team america the the the uh
they're cheering that the u.s women's
soccer team lost americans were happy
about it
no your crowd is happy about it dude
they're cheering
you proved that point before i even said
it
demented okay anyway so so trump almost
seeing
people cheering it as a good thing i
mean what what is considered patriotic
about that i thought this would these
were the people who had the monopoly on
patriotism then in a bizarrely
xenophobic moment trump can't remember
the name of a taliban leader and he just
refers to him as muhammad it's very
strange it's a much different deal
i told the taliban i spoke to the leader
and i spoke i said
let's call him muhammad
i said muhammad
we're leaving yeah so his name is
actually heba tula akunzada but trump
absent remembering he's like well it's a
muslim guy let's just call him muhammad
bizarre moment and of course like the
implicit xenophobia of that going
completely over the crowd's head or not
going over their head but they like it
and then and this is really relevant to
what's going on within the party when
the name mike pence has mentioned the
crowd booze this is a republican crowd
and i only wish that
my friend mike pence had that additional
courage
do
send
to send the results back to the
legislatures because it all happened so
quickly you know they schemed in this
plan for four years this all happened so
the crowd not liking the former
republican president this is a
republican crowd by the way and then
lastly
it all coming full circle trump
describing
a propaganda technique that he's
actually using to convince people of
stuff but that's what they do and you
know what it's called disinformation
they make up a lot of crap and they say
it over and over and over
and
one day
you say oh
who was the one that wanted to defund i
guess it was the republicans
the republicans are against a very
serious so anyway trump's saying
disinformation you repeat something
often enough and people start to believe
it which of course is what he has done
it's it's been his strategy i won i won
i won massive vote dumb so all this
different stuff
that's the technique that he uses he's
identifying a known technique it's just
he's attributing it to the other side so
what are the takeaways here first of all
completely outrageous globally
humiliating speech i mean the fact that
a former president speaks this way is
doing these speeches is saying these
things is absolutely humiliating and in
addition to that in addition to that is
the reality that he still mostly owns
the republican party the crowd is with
him although you have a hand you know
liz cheney who is only with trump 90 of
the time says the the election stuff has
to stop adam kinzinger
who's going to be on the house january
6th commission that starts tomorrow
he's willing to say trump is wrong on a
couple of but he mostly owns the
republican party and so the question is
what happens in 22 with that and what
happens in 24 and i want to hear from
you we'll have more coverage of this
deranged and demented speech on our
instagram at davidpakmanshow you can
leave your comments there or wherever
else you're watching or listening today
let me know your thoughts
one of our sponsors is geology the place
to go for men's skin care geology helps
men find a simple skin care routine that
works it's personalized for you by a
dermatologist and geology can help with
dark puffy eyes acne oily skin
protecting your skin against damage you
answer a few questions about your skin a
dermatologist will design a personalized
skin regimen for your needs you'll get a
30-day trial with the products they
recommend to try them out if you like
how it goes they'll keep sending it to
you these aren't bogus miracle creams
these are just the clinical
evidence-based products that
dermatologists have at their disposal
but they're tailored personally to you
based on the products you really need i
took the quiz a couple of months ago
their dermatologist matched me with a
regimen that's just great for me i've
been happy with the results my skin's
looking great i can actually see a
difference go and take geology's free
quiz and when you use my link right
underneath this video
you will save up to 40 percent off your
first paid month